foreign
[Music]
Fades away the opposite is happening the
more the government is trying to push
the very what they call legislation
judicial reform which is more than
Constitution vandalism the more people
in the streets and the more the police
is using false against them it's really
important that we raise awareness all
around the world so not just in Israel
but all over
tries to do what they're trying to do
here people will go out and demonstrate
[Music]
again
from low and to protest against our
crime Minister that we call him crime
Minister he is becoming a dictator
and we don't want the title shape we
want democracy thank you